[MUSIC PLAYING]
JEFFREY BARZACH: I really
wanted to figure out
what it was like to be
in a bonding experience
with a group of people.
I feel like that's
something very special
where a group of people
are just together,
and perform songs,
and do activities.
And Outdoor Action gave
me that venue to do that.
And I feel like that is a much
more team building experience
and to meet new people,
other incoming freshmen,
and build friendships that way.
CAREN JU: Outer Action
seemed fun and a good way
to introduce yourself
to new people.
You can get caught up every day
in studying and doing whatever
to prepare for your future.
But when you stop, and you
experience the outdoors,
you know how precious
life is and how much
you can appreciate the
little things that you have
while you're camping.
WENDY HO: My advice to the
incoming and first year
students is really get
to know your class.
I think during my first year, I
was trying to do way too much.
And I didn't spend
enough time just getting
to know the people
at Princeton, which
I think is arguably the most
important part of Princeton.
So just spending
time with people
and really being
intentional about your time.
FAWAZ AHMAD: Spending several
days outdoors with people
I've never met, doing activities
I've never done, in a place
I've never been to--
so all of these
things, I think, really
go along with the spirit
of college in itself--
exploring new things,
challenging parts of yourself
that you didn't even
know existed before,
and meeting new, awesome
people and doing awesome things
with them.
[MUSIC PLAYING]